تحصل زواج احد اهم الاسباب الوقائيه من
امراض وراثيه عديده الا ان البعض لا يدرك
اهميه اخذ نتائج الفحص بجديه والنتيجه
ابناء مصابون بمرض او امراض وراثيا
العربيه التقت احد المواطنين في شرق
السعوديه عناء وما زال يعاني من قرار
زواجه بدون فحص
[موسيقى]
علي القريش الذي تزوج في نهايه السبعينات
لم يدرك بان اول ابنائه سيكون مصابا بمرض
فقر الدم المنجلي بسبب غياب فحص ما قبل
الزواج انذاك رحله من المعاناه عاشها
الابن مع المرض الذي اثر على طفولته
ومراهقته في السابق يعني ما كان اول فيه
فحوصات ما قبل الزواج يعني قديما ما كان
في الامور هذه موجوده
بكون ان يعني الطب الان يعني
طور فاشوف ما شاء الله الان يعني الفحوصات
هذه ما قبل الزواج هذي قاعده تسوي حلول
وتسوي حد من
الامراض هذه الوراثيه كنت اشوف كل الاطفال
يزاولوا كامل
متعتهم في المكان ده ما عاده انا يعني كان
ابغى اسبح بحر ممنوع ابغى اسبح في بركه
ممنوع ابغى ازاول الشغله الفلانيه ممنوع
كلها كانت ممنوعه
خوفا على صحتي يعني احمد احد المصابين
بمرضه فقر الدم المنجلي فضلا الالتزام
بفحصه ما قبل الزواج والارتباط بفتاه
سليمه لضمان انجاب ابناء اصحاء قررت ان
انا اتزوج واخذ انسانه سليمه ما تعاني من
هذا المرض
عشان نجيب هذه الاولاد سليمين والحمد لله
رب العالمين وهذا من فضل الله سبحانه
وتعالى ينتشر في السعوديه ما يقرب من 235
مركزا معتمدا للفحص الطبي قبل الزواج في
منشاه القطعين الحكومي والخاص بحسب موقع
وزاره الصحه والتي تقدم الفحص الطبي
للمقبلين على الزواج وتقديم الاستشارات
الطبيه لغير المطابقين تجنبا لتكوين اسره
غير سليمه صحيا في عندنا الفحص عن الامراض
الوراثيه وتشمل امراض فقر الدم المنجلي او
السيكل سيل وامراض الثلاثين بالنسبه الى
الجانب الثاني هي الكشف عن الامراض
المعديه وتشمل التهاب الفيروسات الكبد نوع
باء جيم بالاضافه الى فيروس نقص المناعه
المكتسب والذي يؤدي الى مرض الايدز بعض
المضاعفات تكون اكثر شيوعا في الاعمار
الصغيره وبعض المضاعفات تكون اكثر شيوعا
في حال التقدم التقدم بالسن لكن كل الفئات
العمريه معرضه لمضاعفات المرض من القطيف
علي اللغبي العربيه
ومعنا في استديوهات هنا من الرياضه
الدكتور ماجد الفاضل نائب المدير التنفيذي
لمركز الملك عبد الله العالمي للابحاث
الطبيه حياك الله دكتور سعداء بوجودك معنا
انا اكثر والله شرفني ذلك دكتور اولا هل
الفحص فحص ما قبل الزواج يعني
يمنع جميع الامراض الوراثيه حاليا الاجابه
لا فحص ما قبل الزواج يمنع عن الانيميا
المنجليه وانيميا البحر المتوسط حاليا فقط
لكن في توجه كبير ان شاء الله من قطاعات
يعني كثيره انه نوسع من الفحص
الوراثي قبل الزواج ليشمل اكثر الامراض
المعروفه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه باي
قدر ترى ان هناك وعي عند الناس اليوم يعني
في اهميه الفحص ما قبل الزواج
بدءا من من توقيت اشتراطه وحتى اليوم
سؤال ممتاز جدا
الوعي صراحه تحسن بشكل كبير كبير جدا
يعني في دراسه قبل فتره عملت عن مدى الوعي
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه عن فحص ما
قبل الزواج لقينا في تحسن بنسبه 50% او
الباحثين اللي عملوا هذا هذه
المقاله وجدوا انه 50% في تحسن وهذا شيء
طيب لكن حنا نامل انه يكون من تسعين الى
مئه بالمئه
ممكن يعني عده عوامل كثيره منها يعني يمكن
نحتاج اكثر حملات توعويه حملات ارشاديه
نحتاج اكثر انواع عيال الناس انه عن
الامراض الوراثيه وعن الجينات وما هي
الجينات في كثير يعني حتى من المتعلمين ما
يفهم وش معنى العلم حقنا الى الان هل ما
زالت في
في يعني حالات رصدتوها فيها اصرار من
الطرفين او من طرف واحد على اكمال الزواج
بالرغم من وجود نتائج ايجابيه
هي نتائج ايجابيه تصير للفحص ما قبل
الزواج عن احتماليه لامراض وثائق وراثيه
يعني يمكن ان تتعرض لها العائله طبعا اذا
كان
الخطيب والخطيب حاملين لنفس الجين في نسبه
25% في كل حمل انه يكون الطفل مصاب و75%
انه يكون الطفل سليم فهذه النسبه الاعلى
انه يكون سليم بس لسه في 25% انه يكون
الطفل مصاب
فوجدنا بعضهم
يعني يغامروا ويصر على الاقبال على الزواج
رغما لانهم حاملين للمرض لعوامل كثيره
منها اجتماعيه ومنها اشياء اخرى على الرغم
من انهم عارفين انه راح يعني يرزقوا
بمولود ممكن يكون مصاب بمرض وراثي وبياثر
على
وشفنا نماذج كثيره يعني يمكن الناس
ندمت انها لم يعني تلتزم بنتائج الفحص
مثلا يعني صحيح صحيح مصرين في ناس مصرين
طيب هذا ما هو يعتبر عيب اصلا في في او
مشكله في مساله الفحص الوراثي يعني انا
ارى انه مثلا يجب ان يكون الامر حازم في
هذه يجب ان يمنع الطرفين من الزواج بسبب
هذه النتائج لانه الخساره ستكون مؤلمه على
الاسره وعلى المجتمع وعلى يعني الكل يعني
في هذه الحاله سيكون شريك في هذه الماسه
سؤال ممتاز جدا صراحه لكن حنا كاطباء او
او حتى المشرعين ما نقدر نمنع بشكل تام
لعوامل اجتماعيه وعوامل اخلاقيه يعني احنا
اذا راينا من الجانب العلمي فقط ممكن لازم
نكون حازمين لكن لما نكون نراها من الجانب
الاجتماعي فمثلا هذه الزوجه
او الزوج لو لو منعتهم يمكن ما تتزوج مره
اخرى فاهم علي في حيزيد مستوى العنوسه في
المجتمع فهذه الاشياء الاجتماعيه مهمه جدا
وايضا الاشياء الاخلاقيه يعني حنا
نسميه سكرينج يعني
فحص مسحي لانسان طبيعي فهذا لازم يكون
اختياري كليا ما يكون شيء اجباري فمن
اخلاقيات الطب انه لازم يكون اختياري وليس
اجباري كيف يتم التعامل في مثل هذه الحاله
دكتور ماجد التوعيه اهم شيء التوعيه
التوعيه والارشاد ايش تقولوا لهم يعني
نشرح لهم ونجيب لهم يعني قصص حيه وبعض
الاحيان ممكن
نوريهم اذا كان فيه عائله متعاونا نجيب
الطفل المصاب ونوريهم ونشرح لهم ونقول لهم
وايضا نعرض عليهم اللي هو الوقايه بحيث
انه نفحص فحص الجيني ونحدد الطفره وبعدين
نعمل الوقايه اللي هي الوقايه عن طريقتين
اللي هي السائل الامنيوسي ناخذ عينه من
يوسي ونشيك على نفس الطفره اللي لقيناها
عند
اللي هم الخطيبين اذا الطفل سليم اذا مصاب
يجهز قبل نفر يروح قبل نفخ الروح اللي قبل
والطريقه الاخرى اللي هي الفحص الوراثي
قبل الانغراس او اطفال الانابيب في فرق
بيننا وبين دول حولنا في منسوب او مستوى
الوعي او في دول اخرى متقدمه بالفحص
الوراثي والالتزام بنتائجه احنا نعتبر من
يعني من اعلى الدول في فحص الوراثي
والجيني والتقدم في الامور هذه
والحمد لله يعني حاليا
الناس يقارن ترى بالدول الاوروبيه والدول
يعني شمال امريكا والدول الاخرى يعني
الوعي في هذه الامور متقارب جدا حتى في
الدول اللي سبقتنا في هذا المجال